the Trump administration is apparently
planning to move hundreds of
undocumented immigrants to South Florida
local officials in Broward and Palm
Beach counties say they have been told
to expect plane loads of migrants from
South Texas starting in about two weeks
Ben Tracy is at the White House Ben good
morning good morning so far the White
House has not officially confirmed this
plan but last month President Trump did
say he was considering a plan to send
illegal immigrants to so-called
sanctuary cities it's not clear if he is
now making good on that threat this has
to be the most inhumane act that can be
happened by the president moving people
from Texas border cams to Florida is an
unwelcome surprise for local officials
just no real plan on what's going to
happen to these five hundred people
every month that's going to come to Palm
Beach County it's no secret that migrant
camps in the US border are overcrowded
but the mayor of Palm Beach County says
this is not a solution we want better
plan from our federal government we are
not a border state the mayors have been
told to expect to plane loads of
migrants each week up to 1,000 people a
month split between Palm Beach in
Broward counties both are Democrat
strongholds but don't consider
themselves sanctuary cities the migrants
do not face criminal charges but would
likely be released into the community
awaiting immigration hearings Florida
Senator Marco Rubio wrote a letter
demanding answers from the Department of
Homeland Security immigrants must be
financially self-sufficient on Thursday
President Trump announced his new plan
for legal immigration based on so-called
merit rather than family connections or
diversity it prioritizes immigrants and
high-paying professions and those who
speak English we discriminate against
brilliance we won't anymore
once we get this past Democrats say the
president's plan is offensive merit it
is really a condescending word they're
saying family is without merit are they
saying most of the people have ever come
to the United States in the history of
our country are without merit
because they don't have an engineering
degree
the president is tweeting about
immigration this morning in a tweet he
just sent out he said all people that
are illegally coming into the United
States will be removed at a later date
he goes on to say don't make yourselves
too comfortable you will be leaving soon
yes he has a lot to say on Twitter this
morning thank you very much Ben